um for me
men and women are the price to each
other
okay how
um
okay I don't accept that answer pick one
yeah pick one men or women someone has
to reach someone someone's a prize
[Music]
in the pursuit
for happiness I think women are the
prize okay
um but as you you kind of cut off my
answer so I can't give you the answer I
wanted to give but in that yeah women
are the prize for men okay what do you
guys think I feel like women are the
prize I feel like from a young age I've
always seen the woman just sits there
and the man is always chasing after the
woman so it just looks like the woman is
the prize okay
um
I think
it depends on what stage of life you're
at for me personally I think if we're
gonna go like just we're just looking
right now I would say women are the
prize as in she's the trophy on your arm
you kind of create her as to what looks
good for you you take her out you get
the all of the compliments that's your
woman she's amazing but I think as a
woman I just think
I don't know I feel like it works but
like what she said I just feel like the
age I'm act we should both be apprised
to each other like there should be some
middle ground or I can't expect a man to
do everything same way he I'm very
traditional but we have to adapt to the
to the world that way and if that makes
sense so I think if you just want me to
say yes or no I would say women are the
prize from a young age you're cute your
hair is long you're this you're that
however I think as you grow up you
realize Marvel's values like even
beliefs like do you get it I feel like
those things are all things that
intertwine and will defend what was
determine if you're a prize if you're
some people are beautiful but then
that's the inside so I have a question
you said you're traditional how are you
traditional if you're not married
because then you wouldn't you have
traditional outcomes well me personally
I think I'm traditional in terms of my
modes and my beliefs in regards to men
and women so when I say I think I've
watched your podcast before you go talk
about submission I know this generation
anti-submission yeah yeah XXX yeah but I
believe we're in a world where men and
women are not equal yes we should be
ideally not and I think that as you get
older you just need to understand
yourself I'm not gonna go and project
myself into someone's son I need to have
my stuff together but it's
psychologically spiritually financially
in check and then we can do it together
I don't think there's a Time form or you
could also be traditional get married
and then get divorced so at the end of
the day I just think well I would say if
I got divorced I wouldn't be traditional
then like because to me like a
traditional traditional outcomes you're
married with kids like I don't think you
can say you're traditional no that's the
end goal 100 yeah but I'm saying like
until you have traditional outcomes how
can someone claim to be traditional fair
enough you know I mean I'm not saying
I'm traditional either like I'm not okay
I sorry I I believe that in the
beginning the woman is the prize so as
in in a woman a woman has her prime
stage
and then when she gets to a certain
stage in her life it switches over and
the man becomes the prize so like when
women become
um like I'd say from about 40 onwards
okay
yeah it switches over and the men become
the prize and the women are not so much
the price okay what do you guys think
men or women
pretty much
not even in a way like to say oh I'm 100
let me say why yeah because as a guy
right now
at my age and even in all of our ages
especially like us guys in our 20s
I don't feel like there's what prize
like what do I get from being in a
relationship right now for me personally
in in this current market right now if I
go out with a girl she's gonna get dates
she's gonna get driven around wherever
she's going to go on holidays what do I
get what kind of woman are you looking
for yeah no but okay
what can he get that he can't get from a
hooker and a maid love yeah
what is it what is what does that mean
because a lot of times when I ask girls
this they give like broad statements
without specifics so could I could I
have something specific yeah um so
you're saying that you're gonna date her
take her on holidays I mean a stupid
generally Jennifer yeah good stuff yeah
generally yeah there's no woman on this
planet that will get all that good stuff
and not give you love
I think Amber Heard
Jada Pinkett Smith
there are women who are opportunists
there are women who see that he is the
prize and don't go for it but the thing
is like what I'm saying today like
modern women I think it's a bad deal
yeah
because we're not we're not virgins
anymore like except September
the average age of first marriage in the
UK is 31 so we don't have the youth
anymore
and the Purity so like what what do they
get a better end of the stick which is
what makes us depressed we're going I
was gonna say all right you're saying
the hookah all of that in my in my mind
yeah yeah apart from sex all of that
yeah in my head I feel like you would
have um you know women aren't nurturing
well most women hopefully you would have
that like I'm talking whether it's
um psychological you know you have
people that are your friends before you
get into relationships that friendship
that whole like being there for you ever
is through a mental breakdown that
sincerity of not using you for what you
have I feel like that is what you
potentially would get from a sincere
person if you get what I'm saying from a
friend though like my guy friend okay
but I'm saying but I'm saying like like
that's a woman's point of view because I
think that's what you would want is like
sincerity from a guy but like so a lot
of times like well as girls when we
think about what we want like we
projected under what guys want because
they kind of just want us to shut up
no I think most
I think for most men so like the average
men
um I think women are the prize because
supposedly a lot of men don't get women
so yeah I think women will be the price
but I think the highest or like the most
optimal prize would be a man because
most like they they tend to skew the
market a bit more because like like
Kevin Samuels is his like version of a
high value man or what have you they
seem to be the biggest prize that you
could possibly get in dating power of I
think for most men
women are the price because they don't
get women anyway if that makes sense
well wouldn't you say those guys don't
ever get a woman like because one out of
three men are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year yeah so that's why I
would say like yeah if those type of
guys got a woman they would feel like
they got a prize yeah but I don't really
think they ever get into relationships I
like it to me it's like there's two
types of guys there's a guy that's
always getting girls and then there's
the second one that gets their leftovers
at 30.
I think also it's about Confidence from
the man's perspective of being a lot of
men in this Society are not empowered
and giving confidence to step forth as
men they're kind of they're battened
down to the female perspective of you
know I feel and because I feel this you
must basically accommodate those
feelings and so so sorry finish that's
what you're saying men were allowed to
have the confidence as men in their
masculinity there would be more space
for them to actually pursue women a lot
of men don't know how to talk to women
they don't know how to approach women
because everything's offensive or you
know why are you looking at me well you
dress a certain way I want to look nice
I want guys to look at me when the guy
looks at you why are you looking at me
you get what I mean and so how are Men
supposed to feel confident when 80 when
women find 80 of men is unattractive not
okay or whatever they they literally
think they're unattractive and then
there's another 10 that they find uh
okay maybe here or they're in the last
10 that they'd go first well it's not
first of all biology natural selection
the problem yeah but like how would you
feel if they found 80 of women
unattractive it'd be kind of hard to you
know feel confident in yourself I guess
if you have externalized way your
confidence comes from I think when you
build confidence within yourself and you
know who you are then you step out into
the world as a confident man EG I'll
give you an example and
let's say I don't like to give this
example box for example future to me
he's not a confident man but he projects
confidence into the space where women
will be like oh he's got money you sure
he's made some bold moves some baldness
yeah what do you have to be confident to
project confidence huh like what do you
have to be confident to project
confidence
to some degree at all no no no okay you
can use that you're so projecting
confidence to attract women's attention
and actually getting women are two
different things yeah but what is
self-esteem self-esteem doesn't exist
what do you mean like there's no way to
measure it there's no like self-esteem
isn't real it's just like a thing that
the left says well it is no there's no
there's no statistical way to measure
self-esteem